from dropping out after seriously
injuring someone at an Everclear concert
to being a bit too prestigious for lowly
cameos the reasons these actors refused
roles in Ben Stiller movies are
strangely varied in 1995 Columbia
Pictures paid
$750,000 for firsttime screenwriter Lou
Holt's junor script for the Cable Guy a
dark comedy about a mysterious TV
installer whose friendship with a
customer turns obsessive I just want to
hang out no big de well KY went on to
Star as the infamous chip Douglas the
film was originally intended as a
vehicle for Chris Farley then the toast
of Comedy Hollywood for his work on
Saturday Night Live and Tommy Boy oh my
God according to the AV club Farley was
on board when Colombia hired creative
Partners Ben Stiller and Jud appau to
work on the movie to direct and produce
respectively appau heavily reworked the
script while Stiller decided to take on
the minor double roles of Sam and Stan s
twins on trial obviously guilty of
murdering their parents whose trial airs
live on cable TV the cameras would never
roll on Farley as the cable guy after
the success of Tommy Boy Paramount
Pictures exercised an option on Farley's
contract to make him act in another
movie right away and quickly built the
movie Black Sheep around him that
delayed his involvement as did in
agreement that Farley would start on the
cable guy whenever he left SNL for good
however the comedian didn't want to say
yes to a movie that would film it some
nebulous point in the future so he said
no to the film
altogether although it lasted just one
season and aired to dismal ratings The
Ben Stiller show proved highly
influential in that it created lasting
creative Partnerships among its four
main cast members in the years after the
sketch Show's cancellation Ben Stiller
frequently cast his co-stars in his
directorial projects Janine garoo
starred in reality bites and Bob
Odenkirk appeared in the Cable Guy for
example and when Stiller co-wrote and
ultimately directed and starred in the
geopolitical meets male modeling farce
Zoolander he did so with the Ben Stiller
show alumnus Andy Dick In Mind Stiller
told Esquire Andy Dick was supposed to
play mugatu now it's impossible for me
to picture anybody but will doing it
mugatu is the film's villain a campy and
extremely ridiculous fashion industry
stalwart who hatches a scheme to
brainwash models into killing the prime
minister of Malaysia who wants to end
the sweat shop labor on which mugatu's
industry relies memorably will frell
played the part in the 2001 film in one
of his first major movie roles since
becoming a star on Saturday Night Live
dear God it's beautiful so what's the
reason dick had to pass on a role
written and earmarked for him well he
was busy at the time that Zoolander
entered production dick was committed to
the short-lived NBC sitcom Go Fish which
was then canceled after five episodes
however this didn't stop dick from
showing up for a quick and easy Cameo as
Olga the
masseuse Dante Terrell Smith who now
goes by Yim Bay burst onto the rap scene
in the late '90s under the name most
deaf both as a solo artist and as half
of the duo black star with tald quali he
started making music as a kid and acting
as a teenager and the latter dominated
the performers professional life in the
2000s this included a starring role in
the Pitzer prize winning play Top Dog
Underdog and big Parts in notable flicks
including beind Rewind The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy and 16 blocks B also
almost starred in Tropic Thunder a high
concept action comedy co-written and
directed by Ben Stiller that follows a
band of Misfit actors who wander into a
real war zone while filming a movie
Stiller and collaborators created the
character of alpacino a popular rap
attempting an acting career producers
approached Bae for the part since his
own career trajectory mirrored that of
the character on the page however he
declined the role because he had
objections to the nature of the
character as it was written B told the
ecstatic breakdown it was a conflict in
how we saw the character they wanted it
to be a rap character I wanted it to be
an R&B character for me to do a
character that was a rap parody I wasn't
exactly hyped to do
that there are a lot of bigname actors
in the 2011 Heist comedy Tower Heist a
film that follows a bunch of wronged
workers who decide to rob their boss
after they learned that he has swindled
them out of their money via a Ponzi
scheme we're not criminals we don't know
how to steal the movie features an
All-Star cast including Ben Stiller
Eddie Murphy Casey Affleck Matthew brri
Gabe Cay and Michael Peña turns out it
also almost starred cinematic icon
Robert Redford a longtime a-lister who
took a break from acting in the mid
20000s after his 2007 drama lions for
lambs Redford didn't appear in another
film for 5 years focusing on directing
The Conspirator and the company you keep
the latter of which also marked his
return to acting Tower Heist was
produced and released during that Hiatus
and director Brett Ratner approached
Redford about playing the role of evil
boss and robbery Target Arthur Shaw but
he passed Ratner told cider I think he
was finishing his movie or whatever I
don't know exactly what happened in the
end Alan ala got the part
instead Indie filmmaker Noah bombach
frequently grapples with modern
relationships and in his 2014 drama
While We're Young he explores what
happens to a solid marriage between two
middle-aged people when they meet a cool
hip young couple that make them feel old
and stodgy I love his shoes I have some
wing tips here somewhere I stopped
wearing them when I got Shin spins it
took nearly 4 years for the film to get
made with indiewire reporting casting
news in 2010 that Stiller was set to
Star as the male half of the older
couple while Greta Gerwig would play his
wife Gerwig is a frequent collaborator
of bomback as well as his romantic
partner so this casting made perfect
sense at the time paing Stiller and
gerwick together would have represented
a ret teaming of the leads from bombb
back's 2010 movie Greenberg but it
wouldn't come to pass gerwick left the
film over scheduling issues ultimately
passing the rolloff to Kate Blanchet who
ended up dropping out as well when the
film debuted in theaters in 2014 it was
Naomi Watts who played Stillers on
screen
spouse the Madagascar films have proven
to be a popular and lucrative franchise
for Dreamworks Animation with the three
Flagship films and the Penguins of
Madagascar spin-off pulling in more than
$2.2 billion at the global box office
they're star driven as well with a cast
headed up by the recognizable voices of
David schwimer Chris Rock and Ben
Stiller who plays a lion named Alex
Stiller got his big acting break in 1989
when he joined the cast of Saturday
Night Live but he left after three
episodes at a time in which Dana Carvey
dominated the sketch show Carvey nearly
had a leading role in Madagascar 2 which
would have represented a big part of a
comeback attempt in the late 1990s
Carvey took an extended break from
Hollywood to raise his two young
children and to recover from from a
series of heart surgeries in that time
he passed on two voice acting roles in
what would be two of the most notable
animated features of the mid-2000s
Ratatouille and Madagascar as kby told
people I was very very busy raising kids
at that
time in There's Something About Mary a
movie built around hilarious surprises
perhaps the most unexpected twist comes
when Mary reveals that her mysterious
ex-boyfriend referred to only as Brett
is actually Brett farre the real life
Star quarterback for the Green Bay
Packers Farid won a Super Bowl by the
time There's Something About Mary hit
theaters making him probably the most
well-known football player on the planet
at the time however he wasn't
co-directors Bobby and Peter fi's number
one choice to play Mary's former flame
since the ferelli hail from the Boston
adjacent to New England State of Rhode
Island they originally wanted the then
quarterback of the New England Patriots
Drew bledo to do the Cameo while the
athlete agreed to do the movie he
dropped out before he actually filmed
the scene this was due to a public
incident at the paradise Rock Club in
Boston in which bledo and two patriots
teammates leapt from the stage during an
Everclear concert one of them landed on
a woman seriously injuring her after San
Francisco 49ers QB Steve Young turned
down the role the felis asked Favre to
do the
honors Ben Stiller Zoolander is a silly
movie but its 2016 sequel Zoolander 2 is
even sillier extraordinarily stupid male
models Derek and Hansel reunite in Rome
and find themselves embroiled in another
deadly International conspiracy which
they somehow solve and survive in spite
of their stagger during lack of
intelligence the standout scenes in the
movie involve hansel's personal life in
which he's in a polyamorous relationship
with a relative horde of people both men
and women all of whom he manages to
impregnate how is this even possible we
thought you'd be happy that Arrangement
is depicted in a wildly over-the-top
heavily populated group love scene
played for laughs and in his capacity as
director Stiller tried and failed to add
a very famous and very unlikely face
into the mix former first lady of the
United States Laura Bush he didn't
provide Bush or her reps with the
details of the part but she declined
anyway Stiller told NBC's today and she
was so smart to to politely say no the
Zoolander movies are a sendup of the
world of high fashion so Stiller sought
out a real life representative of that
subculture asking designer and Chanel
creative Chief Carl logger felt to
participate according to hello that was
absolutely out of the question for
logger
Feld by the late 1990s Ben Stiller was
known almost exclusively as a comic
actor this changed in 1998 when he
branched out into much darker and much
more dramatic fair with permanent
midnight which tells the true story of
Jerry stall a TV sitcom writer best
known for Elf Moonlighting and 30s
something who grappled with an addiction
to heroin according to Entertainment
Weekly Stiller prepared extensively and
seriously for his dramatic turn hanging
out with stall and losing 30 pounds to
more effectively get into character
nonetheless Stiller wasn't producers
first choice for the part another upand
cominging actor of the era looking to
prove that he could do more than what he
was known for landed the lead in
permanent midnight the xfiles Mainstay
David Duvy however he pulled out in
order to make the Flop playing God
instead